Yeah,
thank you.
You'll buddy.
Well,
kind of right,
but is there a line where this stops being true?
How much of yourself can you remove before you stopped being you and does the
question even makes sense?
You'll physical existence is cells,
trillions of them at least 10 times more than there are stars in the Milky Way.
A cell is a living being a machine made of up to 50,000 different proteins.
It has no consciousness,
no,
well no purpose.
It just is,
but it is still an individual.
Together.
Your cells form a huge structures for jobs like preparing food,
gathering resources,
transporting stuff around,
scanning the environment and so on.
If you extract cells from your body and put them in the right environment,
they will continue to stay alive for a while so your cells can exist without
you,
but you can't exist without them.
If we take all the cells away,
there is no you anymore.
Is there a line where a pile of your cells stops being new?
For example,
if you donate an organ,
billions of your cells will continue to live on inside someone else.
Does this mean that a part of you became a part of another person or is this
other body keeping a part of you alive or let us imagine an experiment.
You and a random person from the street exchange cells,
one at a time,
your body gets to one of our cells.
That body gets one of your cells.
At which point would they become you?
Would they ever,
or is this just a very slow and gross way to teleport you?
Let's make this more complicated.
The image of ourselves as a static thing is untenable.
Almost all of your cells have to die during your lifetime and 250 million have
died since the beginning of this video alone between one and 3 million per
second.
In a seven year period,
most of your cells are a paste at least once.
Every time yourself set up changes,
you are slightly different than before.
So the part of you is dying constantly.
If you are lucky enough to become old,
you would have cycled through roughly a million billion cells.
So what you consider yourself as ready,
just a snapshot,
but sometimes sells a broken and don't want to die.
Questioning the very nature of the unity of our bodies.
We call them cancer.
They cancel the biological social contract and become basically immortal.
Cancer is not an outside invader.
It's a part of you that puts its own survival over yours,
but you could also argue that a cancer cell,
another entity inside us,
another big that just wants to thrive and survive.
Can we blame it for that?
A chilling sell story is that of Henrietta lacks.
A young cancer patient who died in 1951 usually sells,
only survived for a few days in the lab making research a very hard Henrietta's.
Cancer cells were immortal over the decades.
They were multiplied over and over again and use countless research projects,
saving countless lives.
Henrietta's cells are still alive and overall have been grown to at least 20
tons of biomass.
So there are living parts around the world from someone who has been considered
dead for decades.
How much of Henrietta is in the cells?
What makes one of your cells you anyway?
Maybe the information contained in it,
your DNA.
Until recently it was believed that all the cells in your body had basically the
same genetic code,
but it turns out this is wrong.
You'll genome is mobile changing over time through mutations and environmental
influences.
This is especially the case in your brain.
According to recent discoveries,
a single neuron and an adult brain has more than 1000 mutations in its genetic
code that are not present in the cells surrounding it,
but how much you is your DNA.
Really about 8% of the human genome is made up of viruses that once infected our
ancestors and merged with us.
Mitochondria power plants at the cell once were bacteria that most with the
ancestors of your cells,
they still have their own DNA.
An average cell has hundreds of them,
hundreds of little things that are not really human,
but they still kind of,
ah,
this is confusing.
Let's backtrack a bit.
We know that you're made up of trillions of little things made from more little
things.
There's a constantly changing together.
All those little things are not static,
but dynamic composition and condition is changing constantly.
So we might just be a self sustaining pattern without clear borders that gained
self awareness at some point and now has the ability to think about itself
through time and space,
but ready only exists in this exact very moment.
Where did this pattern start with your conception?
When the first human arose,
when life first began conquering our small planet,
when the elements that make up your body were forged in a star,
our human brains evolved to deal with absolutes.
The fuzzy borders that make up Rhianna's e are hard to grasp.
Maybe ideas like beginning and end life and death.
You and me are really not absolute,
but ideas belonging to a fluent pattern,
a pattern that is lost in this strange and beautiful universe.
Okay?
The problem of who we are isn't just a question of ourselves,
but it's also a question of our minds just as our cells can be divided and
separated from us.
So can our very brains be divided and separated from us while still in the
skull?
Click here to go to my channel and watch the next part.
Okay,
so now go watch CGP grades video.
If you're not yet subscribing to his channel,
you should really change that.
Now.